[Musique]
évidemment
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans leurs tiroirs de canal a
dit avoir le premier
sur la vie
les deux équipes qui vont s'affronter
sans
la reine du boulevard chantal l'est
et la maj de bref s'est fait un nom
bérengère krief
elle supporte aymeric caron toutes les
semaines léa salamé
sarkozy est revenu pour lui stéphane
guillon
ces deux équipes de personnalités bon
jouer sur le thème qu'elle préfère elle
même
l'enjeu est simple l'équipe gagnante
aura le droit de faire plus de promo que
l'autre aurait pas
d'accord vous du spectacle au grand
point virgule au bâtiment est un ancien
vous donc votre promo c'est le livre qui
s'est déjà vendu à 35 mille exemplaires
et la pièce tous les soirs à 19h au
théâtre antoine inconnu à cette adresse
voilà l bruno avec bruno solo à brno est
formidable et le 23 janvier au théâtre
antoine de nouveau avec une pièce sur le
système de l'os mais on n'en dit pas
plus il faut que vous gagnez pour en
parler absolument thierry
[Applaudissements]
mois la promo et tout ça c'est on n'est
pas couché et concepteur
l'italie peut se réveiller peut-être un
peu déséquilibré d'avoir mis les deux
blondes ensemble
faut pas qu'on se qualifie les volets
des fausses blondes
vous êtes prêt à tout toute
première épreuve le bio quiz
le principe est simple
chacun d'entre vous va faire l'objet de
deux questions sur sa vie mais ça sera à
l'autre équipe de répondre évidemment un
point par bonnes réponses on commence
avec votre vie avoue chantal ladesou
voilà léa et stéphane c'est à vous de
répondre attention moi je ne réponds pas
maintenant
de réfléchir un minimum sinon ça va être
pénible
c'est je fais du boulevard sainte-anne
enchaîne les succès au théâtre en ce
moment c'est nelson au théâtre de la
porte saint-martin juste avant c'était
un dieu je reste avec isabelle mergault
au théâtre des variétés
mais cela ne fait pas oublier que
chantal est avant tout maman une maman
qui a marié à l'été 2013 son fils julien
mais c'est
chantal ladesou oui pour belles filles
une ex miss poitou charentes ex
catcheuses professionnelles
ex miss météo de canal+ ou ex de silvio
berlusconi
ex miss météo oui ne fait bordeaux
le premier point de la partie dès
l'ouverture du score
chantal est assurément la reine du
boulevard mais elle a aussi exercé son
talent au cinéma dans des films
mémorables dans lequel de ses fils
chantal ladesou at-elle effectivement
joué les brésiliennes du bois de
boulogne
les zooms before l'espagne
midas à saint tropez et les charlots à
ibis
[Musique]
moi c'est difficile c'est au cinéma que
j'aime donc je l'emmerdé
[Rires]
ben ouais séoul et charles où les
bidasses et voilà c'est pas les
brésiliennes ont les zombies font
l'espagne non les bidasses à saint
tropez arnaud
on peut demander l'avis du public non
aux excuses moi je confonds à tous
réponse et par moi je tirais les
évidences les bidasses à saint tropez
mauvaise
c'est quoi ben c
était une prostituée à venir '
et il faut dire chantal que vous aviez
pris du plaisir à faire soi-même et
har-homa vraiment drogué quelqu'un qui
s'est arrêté qui va moitié
du chiffre
d'affaires de temps en temps un petit
tour votre frère
stéphane et les abos continue à jouer
mais cette fois avec bérengère krief
jouer non non c'est sûrement
ça doit pas être facile
on est d'accord avec moi en tout cas ça
joue la tension née en 1983 bérengère
fait partie de cette nouvelle génération
d'humoristes fille qui n'hésite pas à
appeler un chat un chat et une chatte
une chatte la scène bérangère la
pratique le plus souvent seul mais
parfois c'est à plusieurs
avec une bande d'amis bérengère krief a
créé le beach comedy club le
comedy club le kaunas comedy club où le
djamila comedy club
[Musique]
c'est toi qui es maurice sais pas si
c'est pas facile
[Musique]
et à son senna ce nom oui les deux
marches moi j'aurais dit moi si
je faisais partie de la bande j'aurai
les à la péta aussi choquant ce métier
je repousse au
[Rires]
national comedy club qui sont les autres
kaunas christine berrou nadia roz anne
sophie girard ce qui est drôle c'est que
le tag line du spectacle c'est parce
qu'on a tous une en nous oui
même toi jean louis
goût de 12 heures non mais tu commences
pas flipper les athlètes il faut avoir
le moral connaissent pas grand chose
mais c'est un inconnu c'est très connu
bérengère et lyonnaise elle est montée à
paris en 2005 à l'époque elle s'inscrit
à plusieurs courts pour se perfectionner
notamment l'école du one man show à elsa
existe mais quand on pratique l'humour à
haute dose comme le fait bérengère il
faut s'entourer des meilleurs auteurs
évidemment
bérengère krief a coécrit son spectacle
avec un ancien auteur de michel leeb un
ancien auteur de popeck un ancien auteur
de florence foresti ou un ancien auteur
de blagues carambar
merci foresti mais je crois que
maintenant
également déclaré grégoire d'actifs qui
a été auteur pour les blagues carambar
et qui a été aussi metteur en scène de
jérôme daran
met en scène ses fins j'aimerais moi
j'aurais tribus et des droits d'auteur à
mon metteur en scène parce que le
metteur en scène il te donne des idées
alors je quitte
ma demande et on va demander à dieu un
demi point à dieu à dieu
qu'est ce que tu en penses je leur donne
le point ou pas bonsoir mon fils et
niort
ce ne sont que quelques points
[Musique]
sur
votre score
le score est de 1
[Applaudissements]
je reconnais que c'est pas énorme on
continue avec voulait à chantal hébert
voudrait couvre la chouette attention se
concentre
avant de devenir stagiaire sur la chaîne
parlementaire public sénat où elle fera
ses premières armes avec jean pierre
elkabbach l'oea avait suivi de
brillantes études de droit puis elle a
fait sciences po paris alors qu'elle
était étudiante sa vie aurait pu
complètement basculé à quoi
né à salah mais at elle échappé de
justesse en 2001 un mariage forcé avec
un saoudien
à l'attentât youtube wall trade center à
une attaque de requin en australie
ou un dîner aux chandelles avec
dominique strauss kahn
redire la réponse b c'est à dire
attentat l'attentât du world trade
center qui tourne
non mais ça donne donne la réponse
d'entre elles sera plus facile pourquoi
les mines en 2000 revenus la mémé
septembre 2001
non franchement lamentable pensé qu'elle
allait répondre à un mariage forcé ouais
bah non pas non parce que l'on vit banel
sont souvent mariés à des saoudiens
quelle est la couleur du cheval blanc
d'henri iv c'est là c'est la prochaine
[Rires]
il faut dire c'est vrai ce qui veut dire
si vous êtes sorti acheter un croissant
mais les classements la ben laden à
envoyer ses avions charles de gaulle
trade center un lien avec les saoudiens
bonne réponse a entendu une énorme
déflagration
oui non mais j'étais vraiment en dessous
est blessé et blessé les tpe
à bloc du ventre et center c'était qu'on
en parle et là comme ça on met entre
l'âge c'est une émission de
divertissement
est-ce que tu être ma ville et non sa
polaire et les plus traumatisants
attention alors qu'elle officie sur i
télé dans un certain anonymat il faut
bien le dire les as devient soudain la
star des réseaux sociaux c'était le 28
août 2013 facilité et on appelle ça un
buzz
alors qu'elle ignorait qu'elle était à
l'antenne avec quelle phrase
et à cela mais a fait le buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux
je me demande vraiment comment elle fait
julie gayet
j'ai vraiment l'air d'une bouffe avec
cette jupe j'ai fait péter le décolleté
ou quelle conne 7 nadine morano
à
france info
et un piège et anglaise ya bien
évidemment il ya un gros piège le genre
de pierres non non
je vous dis oui mais ça marche
c'est plus difficile et qu'il n'y a pas
la réponse a
observé tout allait alors que tu es une
information qu'on avait dans notre tête
attention alors atteint jeffrey white a
raison moi je crois que vous avez ça
mais après j'ai en tout réponse c'est la
réponse est je j'ai fait péter le décode
beau
gosse qui restera dans les annales de la
télévision au même titre que sucer c'est
tromper mais elle a souvent dit quelle
conne nadine morano souvent le mur en
même temps ça aurait pu être la réponse
vous regrettez d'avoir dit çà oui c'est
vrai
maintenant c'était gentil c'est une
étude maubon ça va me coller aux basques
basque
cette fois que je viens chardy 6 mai
ressort ses deux enfants ce qu'ils
dégagent
maintenant on a travaillé pendant neuf
ans avant longtemps et on a toujours été
très correct - massage en belgique ou
pas bien si jamais
on termine avec votre vie avoue stéphane
à bombay s'il est revenu à ses premières
amours le cinéma le théâtre
stéphane guillon a explosé aux yeux du
grand public grâce à sa langue bien
pendue et à sa plume acérée humoriste
chroniqueur billettiste c'est stéphane
qui se définit le mieux lui même
stéphane guillon se qualifie lui-même de
des proches de supérettes
coluche de supermarchés devos orapé ben
laden de la gaudriole
[Applaudissements]
cette année
déjà sérieusement ouais c'est bien c'est
tout c'est touchant c'était sa main on
essaie d'être quand même un moment
à des proches ou
se qualifie lui même jeté proche de
superman
[Applaudissements]
les attaques sur le physique stéphane
les a parfois pratiqué il faut dire les
choses avec nos petits malins non mais
ça vous fait plaisir donc vous êtes eric
besson non mais tout ça est faux mais
dites que vous allez j'avoue c'est comme
quand vous dites que vous avez jamais
soutenu hollande non je suis marié j'ai
mis une photo de lancer comme vous quand
je vous dis moi je dis que je vivrai je
vis mais nathan avec des femmes de plus
de 18 ans tout ça c'est des conneries
aussi
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire
c'est qu'en fait stéphane guillon ne
s'épargne pas lui même
d'après sa propre description
stéphane guillon dit qu'il a la bouche
en cul de poule
les oreilles en chou-fleur
le sexe en tire bouchon
où l'oeil en couille de loup
on va dire les quatre noms
[Musique]
alors
comment ce dernier est un peu pénible
cette question parce que si on dit un
truc et que c'est pas ça on passe pour
des
serveurs bérengère alors j'ai pas peur
visiter avec ceux ayant eu lieu
c'est pas facile à dire alors
ah les lie en couille de l'eau oui
il allait en coulis de l'eau
très très fort à lestrem et le sexe non
non
déjà beaucoup de bouteilles d'eau
ya beaucoup de bouteilles
à l'issue du bio quiz le score est de 1
pour vous
et pour bérengère et chantal les 2 4
ans on retrouve après la pub pour la
suite bien qui est le premier jeu basé
sur la vie de ces candidats a tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais de canal
sur la vie de ces candidats nous sommes
toujours en cours baby blues
touchant
elle s'est fait un nom
elle supporte aymeric caron tous les
samedis
et deux sarkozy pauli
robalé score je crois qu'on va les
donner le score 6 4 1 ouais kkp pour eux
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec la deuxième épreuve
l'auto quiz
alors le principe est simple chacun de
vous or à 60 secondes pour répondre à un
maximum de questions sur sa propre vie
chaque bonne réponse rapporte un point
on va voir si vous vous connaissez bien
vous même chantal ladesou concentre
vous êtes venu combien de fois dans
happy hour son talent
nero fois c'est la première fois
dans l'un de vos sketchs vous dites que
vous êtes addict à ikea savez vous quel
type de meuble s'appelle arkel storck
chez ikea sénart mois bo
[Applaudissements]
laquelle je suis ouvert et pouvoir est
né un 29 et alors ça lui fait 84 bravo
[Applaudissements]
parmi les gens que vous avez côtoyé qui
est françois nazaire simon des six ans
alors là non ça s'est rien passé est
passé cinq ans chez place
non j'arrête ça vous bouffe du temps
effectivement bien sûr et qui c'est
fabrice ah bon c'est vrai que ça va
manger tu étais bessines
c'est fou que la détruit quand même
choisi fabrice la bri
extravaganza ici en général soit tu
t'appelles fabrice au départ tout ouïe
ouïe et choisir fabrice comme à la sas
de françois la place de françois marie
comme quoi attention un repas
quelle était votre nom dans la série
magee
madame madame boutin
donc se situer l'action de la série
maggie au chesnay non à montfort
l'amaury à 4 mais aussi à
faire tous les hauts-de-seine
c'est pas mauvais au vésinet déploré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez c'est dommage et dommageable c'est
moi même je le rappellerai tout mais
d'après vous quels produits de luxe à la
même odeur
[Applaudissements]
d'après vous quels produits de luxe à la
même odeur que la gonzesse qui se
néglige ses 1 tonne de mon sketch un
produit de luxe
cavia non un truc comme ça on donne le
point oui comment sont elles le font ces
semences est ce mon épouse est vous
donner les réponses vous n'avez pas que
cet art et bois
[Applaudissements]
dieu je lui donne le point poids pour
monfils
[Applaudissements]
attention on passe avoue beranger
donc combien épisode de bref avez vous
joué on a trois gros après j'ai des
petits trucs dans les autocars
neufs oui
j'ai lu le véritable prénom de kyan
khojandi le créateur de brefs kian bravo
à cannes interne formaté avez vous
répondu lorsque vous êtes venu dans
salut les terriens
le pire de ballons
combien coûte un gramme de cannabis
sarah pour un allways avons
pas je passe maintenant c'est pas vous
qui l'a acheté
tu sais pas si
c'est cet euro
ces 6 euros tu te fait enfler pas
reconduit le
mouvement
agaçant
comment s'appelait votre personnage dans
la série hero corp britney bravo
selon le magazine in situ quelle place
occupe et vous au classement des filles
les plus drôles de france
je crois que c'est les 35 non 14 ne
commence à peler la pièce de théâtre
dans laquelle vous avez joué quand vous
aviez 14 ans la maison de bernarda alba
bien sûr ya réalisé le court métrage
machination dans lequel vous avez joué
armement très bien quelle est votre
signe dans l'horoscope chinois
cauchon
36 à moi alors ses 14
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec vous les âges stéphane
l ea c'est à vous de jouer d'accord
attention
quel magazine a titré léa salamé un cow
boy en talons un glee quelle
personnalité vous avez écrite à vos
débuts comme un gros bébé de 23 ans
qu'abbas sorti de sciences po vous
captez à beyrouth quelle est la devise
du liban
se passe honneur sacrifice loyaux talpa
satanique
dormez pas couché un câlin vite
avez-vous dit sam a éclaboussé de
virilité votre film ul non
oui mais gitan le gitan luigi non non
mais
gitton autant pour noir et au tampon
quelle a été la première radio à
diffuser la gaffe vous avez fait en
direct sur i télé fun radio fun radio
quel était le chef du gouvernement
libanais quand votre père était mini la
culture carrez qui vous a demandé sur le
plateau de on n'est pas couché si votre
habileté du vrai cuir
caron nom isabelle mergault sur ce même
plateau quel chanteur a cru ou faire un
compliment en disant c'est dans les
vieux pots qu'on fait les meilleures
qu'en dit voilà
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il a dit exactement c'est
vrai
c'est pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas
bien quand il parle mais un truc comme
dans les vieux pots qu'on fait les
meilleures soupes
bah oui at il été draguée banon mais
parce que je soulignais son âge quand la
différence d'âge 18-39 ans déjà les
agréments réflexion j'ai pensé à ma non
mais il l'a fait avec beaucoup
d'humanité oui
là une grille montant
son truc là on est tombé sur le plateau
du casse couille d'un
côté on a vu que les nuggets ont avec
leur
vrai jour
vous souvenez de la pièce que laurent
ruquier vous a emmené voir en novembre
dernier oui michèle bernier et de
l'hôpital ma meilleure amie ou restons
amis il vaut mieux qu'on reste amis
demain
là j'arrête le renvoi nouzonville un
pardon pardon lors de l'eurovision
vouloir vraiment préfère qu'on reste
amis
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans quel théâtre antoine ça va ça
va sur le plateau d'on n'est pas couché
à quelques personnalités politiques à
lui demander s'il était vraiment fait
mobilis dix fois plus haut
[Applaudissements]
non
magnifique le jeune
stéphane tu es prêt oui pas si tu es
jeux parce qu'elle perd quelle personne
multi faisait un jour toi tu n'as pas ta
langue dans sa poche des eaux mais il
faudrait non non
non c'est un patch et on tombe parents
ne va pas je crains bien ce qu'a dit léo
tu veux citer dit oh toi tu n'as pas ta
langue dans sa poche mais il faudrait
t'en servir autrement est-ce que tu
connais le clitoris à ça valait le coup
le clitoris un truc de filles
attention
dans le film le temps de la kermesse est
terminé
quelques médias allez vous remplacer au
pied levé benoît poelvoorde qu'elle
inutile de l'épisode et navarro dans
lequel vous avez joué la fiancée était
en rouge lamari la marine était brouillé
pas fiancés
[Applaudissements]
mais tu vois je trouve que tu vieillis
mal
il ya deux ans tu leur est tu l'aurais
accepté ça et là t'es plein de petites
et comme ça là
comment s'appelait la directrice de
casting qui vous a conseillé de changer
d'un gros capelier figure devenir garde
risque un brin coquin petit pourcent
près combien avez vous de fans sur
facebook
600 dhs
12600 12000 assure sur twitter 200
milles sur facebook qu'ai je la prendrai
vasic lé vote de ce calcul sur twitter
je veux je trouverai un truc que mieux
la prochaine fois quand on tape
maintenant sur youtube quelle est la
vidéo qui a fait le plus grand nombre de
vues dsk voilà quelques tee dhien a
publié un portrait de vous intitulé
langue de pitre je passe libération
quel est le premier long métrage dans
lequel vous ayez joué on s'en fout
nuance m
secula docteur
michel michel
michel
[Musique]
année c'est pas mal quand même les
contrôles à l'issue de l'auto poulies le
score est de 15 points en un an cette
année
quelqu'un tant ce point chantal ladesou
engin kiev
on continue avec la troisième épreuve le
duo quiz
alors le principe est très simple vous
lance une affirmation vous devez me dire
lequel des membres de l'autre équipe
cela concerne ou bien aucun des deux
chaque bonne réponse rapporte un point
on va voir si vous connaissez vos
adversaires on commence avec vous
chantal et bérangère vous vous jouerez
après d'accord attention parmi vos
adversaires lequel des deux a suivi des
études dans la même promotion que
florian zeller
phan
huy lê à sa manière les astana net à
sciences po avec le grand florian zeller
dont je vous recommande le père et la
mère parmi vos adversaires lequel des
deux a déjà couché avec carla bruni
regarder de haut canada inc
une mauvaise réponse
[Rires]
je suis compliqué à l'écart parmi vous
adversaire lequel des deux a passé des
nuits entières à dormir dans une
baignoire
guillon
comme chantal hay
hassani
la guerre le liban léa salamé était dans
une baignoire la nuit à beyrouth
ya là jamais été aussi propre que parle
aussi
permis aux adversaires lequel des deux
est arrivé en france à l'âge de 5 ans
caché dans le coffre d'une renault 12
ans tient la route
c'était un piège
c'est le piège alors attention
concentrez-vous parmi vous avez un cerf
lequel des deux a fait la coupe de
playboy eau libre
en cas d aucun doute aucun des deux
parmi les adversaires
lequel des deux était le premier a
publiquement évoqué une relation entre
françois hollande et julie gagné c'est
dur ça c'est vraiment
typique
[Applaudissements]
parmi vous avez à faire lequel des deux
figures au classement 2014 des
personnalités de l'année du magazine
jq
[Musique]
lui réponse on c'est fini maintenant
quelques millions
et on y dit non non et on rate et aura
tenté sa folie
témoin j'avais dit les deux les spams
annoncé sans talc est
attention dernière question et faites
gaffe ouais non mais plutôt bien parmi
les adversaires le cueille des deux a
déclaré après l'annoncé du retour de
nicolas sarkozy je place ce jour comme
le plus beau de ma vie avant même la
naissance de négoce
me remit en réunion i où j'espère moi je
vote pour
un carnet de aucun abord
dit des conneries depuis tout à l'heure
mais
le score est de 17 pour vous de 15 pour
le problème c'est qu'ils ont pas encore
joué
c'était difficile mais nous sommes de
retour dans la pierre le premier jeu
besoin du jour en compagnie
chantal ladesou
[Applaudissements]
c'est un nom dès 11h30
toutes les de semaine léa salamé
[Applaudissements]
stéphane guillon
quinze pour vous
17 pour nous
on continue avec le duo police
[Musique]
parmi vos adversaires laquelle des deux
a déjà bossé dans l'une de mes émissions
aucune des deux mois je tairai
aucune des deux et non chanteuse pour
chantal ladesou dans double jeu elle
n'est maquilleuse maquilleuse de plateau
voilà diallo mais tout le monde garde un
bon souvenir pour
faire des raccord maquillage ainsi
parmi vos adversaires laquelle des deux
a déjà vendu des fruits araji
vas-y vas-y un jeu où il faut jouer à
l'instar des sujets
[Musique]
parmi vous avez un cerf de laquelle des
deux un chat prénommé journaux elle
gisait là là là je me suis planté deux
fois cette fois-là de sortir comment il
s'appelle le chat jean noël augert noël
moi je pense que chantal est
suffisamment tordu bombe a rappelé
chantal la pause
c'est bon ça il a même un facebook ah
ouais j'en aurai le félin pour ses
querelles ajoutée comme le chat de la
guadeloupe est ouais parmi vos
adversaires laquelle des deux à un
poisson rouge nommée mustapha faire toi
on va perdre toute la ménagerie la sega
ses gaffes
et cadets 2 aucun parmi les adversaires
laquelle dd a déjà sauté d'une voiture
lors d'une scène de ménage
chantal ladesou telles actions donnent
c'est toi le sol de la voiture en marche
comme mon mari mes emmerdes
comme ça c'est bien alors avant il
venait me chercher maintenant il n'y a
plus moyen
ça fait tellement longtemps que je tends
semble un week-end noir vient pas je
demande du respect entre ici
c'est ma panthéonisation
par les deux adversaires
laquelle des deux a fait l'école du one
man show barlagne en début d'émission
mademoiselle c'est pas grave on prendre
pour un merci
ça rattrape le 11 septembre
parmi vos adversaires laquelle des deux
a eu jean sarkozy comme camarade de
classe à l'école du one man show abbas
et mademoiselle c'est mademoiselle jade
sur moi je pense que c'est un comique
comme son père gardez de marie jo et
n'ont
aucune des deux
adversaires
laquelle 10,2 s'entraîne avec un coach
personnel
[Musique]
chantal sur tablette si bien non c'est
dérangeant
free vient journaux le chat et j'en
finis le coach alors attention rappelle
des points alors là c'est très marrant
parce que finalement vous êtes à 18 ils
sont à 17
c'est très banal
[Applaudissements]
chômage et dont la vue de ces candidats
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
ben moi le premier
de ses candidats nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de la reine du boulevard
chantal ladesou
[Applaudissements]
non bérengère krief support est malade
car ont toutes les semaines léa salamé
est ce que j y revenir stéphane
escor léa salamé stéphane guillon 18
bérengère krief de chantal ladesou 17
c'est pas grave j'ai pas pu imiter
ballon et bien sûr on continue avec la
quatrième épreuve larry quinn
alors principe est simple un tout le
monde joue je vais à l'interview à ma
façon et vous appuyez sur le buzzer
uniquement quand vous avez la bonne
réponse il ya une contrainte ce soient
les réponses doivent se terminer par le
son iq hic alors que vous l'écriviez
hisser cas où y qu eux oui c'est pareil
d'accord aucun appareil ouais c'est au
niveau du son que ça chez nous du son
vous avez compris recueilli que l'icis a
servi à paris d'accord ok je vous donne
un exemple pour bien rouler parce qu'on
est con choisi
quant à la balance
dans quel pays chauds aimeriez vous
vivre en amérique rivaux jambi en
amérique moi ma mère experts
c'est par analyse agnès du sud les shows
l'amérique du sud
marty spa pays non plus mais pape
énoncera continent tu joues avec moi tu
joue pas contre moi
attention quel autre métier auriez vous
préféré faire dans la vie
vendre de la nourriture organique
[Applaudissements]
j'avais aussi un cas pornographie wave
ou y est c'est bon c'est bon dans quel
endroit espérez-vous ne pas aller cette
année au mozambique
le score êtes vous plutôt bon
ça c'est pas bien ça l'aéro vite
j'ai compris ont pesé puis réfléchit à
temps jeudi à genève y
en a qui bossent et qui trouve pas ouais
ben 9 3 points
mais c'est une teigne
indéniable j'enlève 3 allée d'accord
alors on y va me faire des sons avec l
chose ne peut-on pas dire de vous
nos graphiques
une gabegie trop souvent la cuite oui ça
on peut pas dire de toi oui
quels reproches vous fais ton très
souvent
atik pas sympathique
pour quel réalisateur avez-vous de
l'admiration
kubrick
merci terrance manille
à quoi pensez-vous là maintenant
faire un vrai pic nic
[Applaudissements]
on peut quel prénom ne donnerez vous
jamais à votre
dernier mot
ma mère a bien aymeric la mrie
jolie prime
quel objet portez-vous souvent
ap noir c'est la trique
les noirs puent la trique et voilà
[Applaudissements]
attention quel film vous fait encore
marais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il
a nommé
titanic titanic
attention ils sont soit dans à bout de
souffle un méchoui bijoux à 12,1 au lait
de sa mère thierry on le savait basile
continue
[Rires]
vas-y vas-y continue les joues
[Applaudissements]
attention on se calme
quelle est la chose que vous ne
comprendrez jamais les maîtres étaient
visibles
[Applaudissements]
et les verts pluie en premier non non
elle est là puis en premier donc le
buzzer ne sert à rien 6 cores
attention à quel jeu aimiez vous jouez
quand vous étiez petit
elle avait sur meetic
utile décolleté
le saut à l'élastique
mythique sur meetic se dissipe
chargement c'est un jeu pour les enfants
gage de alors quelle serait pour vous le
comble de la misère
créée par un moustique
quelle activité aimez vous pratiquez
après le pique nique la physique le
pique nique keep it ou 8 bien aussi
tunnel et ce type est une équipe quelle
chose un peu coquine aimez-vous bien
qu'on vous fasse dans l'intimité
ah bon un bon coup d'élastiques
merci pour lui
à l'aller
[Applaudissements]
très ludique
ouais
[Applaudissements]
attention à l'issue de lardy quiz les
scores sont de 28
ses fans violents et 2,22
[Applaudissements]
et chantal
et maintenant mesdames messieurs nous
terminons cette émission avec la grande
finale le music quiz
chacun d'entre vous aura le choix entre
deux thèmes mais tout le monde joue un
alors ses deux poings par bonne réponse
vous appuyez sur le buzzer quand vous
avez la bonne réponse hockey chantal oui
est-ce que vous choisissez la météo pour
votre belle fille ou l'école pour vos
débuts dans la classe et la classe la
classe très bien je veux l'interprète
[Musique]
sacré challenge
et voilà ça vous fait deux poids mais
enfin ça va se faire laminer la basse et
moi je suis très mauvais et je soupçonne
chantal de très bonnes et bérangère pas
mauvais c'est donc qu'est-ce que tu
avais bien j'avais je pensais que celle
à moi j'en ai marre aise
non c'est juste c'est juste qu'elles
n'étaient pas nouvelles
quand on connaît mozart on n'était pas
non plus attention david
[Musique]
oh
les enfants font tu de faim
vionnet très touché
il veut des sachets de tricherie qui
c'était
les bras jamais
[Musique]
elle l'a connais parce que la dernière
personne à tenter un soufflage ya de la
triche c'est bien c'est une émisssion
allez on y croit le troisième titre est
un petit peu facile je vais donc vous le
faire écouter sur une sonnerie de
téléphone pourri dhabi
les collectifs
l'interprète
[Musique]
quant aux bijoux les gouttes et celle là
non plus ce n'est qu'un jeu et en plus
elle est très jolie
est-ce qu'il faut dire le titre la
chanteuse et le nom de l'interprète
y avait une possibilité
d'ajustement va demander à dieu
seigneur on lui donne le poiré à
mesure que quelques points
ici c'est dieu qui décide c'est bien
d'avoir du renard est toujours nation
parce qu'avec dieu au moins un voyage et
du coup quand tu appelles temps grosso
modo c'est quand même
attention bérengère vais choisir le
deuxième thème soit sous l'eau pour
monsieur poulpe votre fiancée ou le
chocolat parce que vous adorez le
chocolat
non je prends le chocolat
vous avez de la chance que la première
chanson c'est votre génération si vous
trouvez pas ça c'est grave la pression
la pression maximum david
[Musique]
attend tout le monde joue à
si on connaît pas on ne s'est pas
achevée
cette mesure fait ça à mon avis tu vas
connaître une vieille chanson ou là
attention une vieille attention david
foster
[Musique]
attention le troisième titre est trop
facile on va écouter une cover et vous
allez me dire qui est l'interprète de la
chanson originale
d'avis
mo
[Musique]
la reprise est de gouverner
qui ont été bons sur le fondre mais non
mais
vous allez même où dépasser cela je
tombe bien attention les à vous de
choisir le troisième thème vous avez le
choix entre samedi soir on n'est pas
couché et strip tease pour la faire du
du décollage samedi soir d'accord on
nous vole la vielle du samedi soir
attention david
d'histoire sur la terre cabrel
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous a pris
vous m'avez dit samedi soir j'ai quand
même réfléchir à quelques questions que
le moussem histoire était devant
sa des soirs sur
l'a7 prête david
sacrebleu
on s'acharne
moi je trouve que c'est un peu les
boules de trouver
c'est la gagne alors là c'est énorme ce
qui se passe on est à 32 32 égalité
parfaite
[Applaudissements]
tie break
le troisième titre est trop facile donc
je refais le coût du téléphone pourri
david
dj
jack
[Musique]
bon bien joué alors c'était femme est ce
que vous choisissez la corse si vous
adorez la corse où la famille parce que
tu as une famille ultra nombreuses
je vais prendre la famille parce que si
je trouve pas sur la corse je risque
d'avoir des problèmes
entre muriel et vous êtes à cette info
or on en a 7 ouais ouais ouais ouais et
alors basse écouter ça se passe plutôt
mal
[Applaudissements]
alors là on se concentre sur la famille
les amis la famille d'avis
[Musique]
un
summer camp mehiaoui
we are family
et bêtises non c'est sister sledge qui
sont en fait un groupe créé par nile
rodgers le mague
la peau du second
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
entend personne a trouvé donc finalement
à voilà attention où la belle au sens de
la vie
[Musique]
la pesée du transit en premier maladie
parce qu'elle avait le buzz et
replay mes enfants il plus efficace
[Musique]
les nazis en amical
le dernier titre nous allons l'écouter
en version accélérée
concentrez-vous deux derniers matches
[Musique]
fauconnet le chanteur eddie par titre
je redemande à dire c'est le même litige
en droit qu'est les litiges ben si c'est
que eux ils ont besoin mais c'est vous
qui avez répondu non mais attends je
vais dire que je suis c'est la réponse
bonne que j'ai donnés
je peux pas par rapport à toutes les
allées on a travaillé ensemble et même
personne
[Applaudissements]
il a cherché les années voilà travailler
ensemble non tu peux pas mais on gagne à
l'issue de cette grande finale leahy
stéphane marc 36 points
une chantal et derangère même a que 34
points du cannet faire plus je promets
d'abord
mais nous le perdons mer c'est pas grand
chose à la promo des perdants si on a un
petit truc hein c'est chantal ladesou
nelson au théâtre de la porte
saint-martin c'est tout bah oui
les soirs à 20h et c'est super faut y
aller je sais que c'est super ce que
c'était j'ai pas le droit de le dire
bérengère krief c'était son spectacle de
tournée
oui quand on perd elle va faire
l'olympia est empreint de laëtitia n'a
percé dans l'avion peut pas le dire à la
guerche et le bataclan sinon tu peux
rien dire
[Applaudissements]
et
on peut pas dire que c'est très drôle
non plus non plus
et maintenant on passe mesdames
messieurs rien dire quoi à la promo des
gagnants
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens des sceptiques qui
pensaient que l'exercice d'on n'est pas
couché n'était pas fait pour vous
quelques mois plus tard vous avez mis
tout le monde d'accord avec votre
présence et votre rigueur ce pauvre
aymeric caron passe pour un amateur à
côté et puis y'a france inter tous les
matins à 7h50 c'est extraordinaire
puis sans force
vous étiez les sceptiques quand on en a
maintenant décidé vous prend vous êtes
vous êtes le parrain de la
ddt fans j'étais triste quand vous avez
quitté slt mais j'ai vite compris que
votre véritable passion s'était jouée
sous des formes et d'un fond ça cette
formidable en asie temps inconnu à cette
adresse au théâtre antoine
avec bruno solo exceptionnel
je suis sûr que nous serons formidable
dans le système avec lorànt deutsch à
partir du 23 janvier au théâtre antoine
toujours et à ceux qui ne peuvent pas
aller vous voir au théâtre il ya un lire
via un livre exceptionnel
il s'est déjà vendu à 35 mille
exemplaires
ah oui bon je me délecte
tous les soirs avant de m'endormir ça
s'appelle tout est normal et c'est
publié on cherche voilà
dans cette émission il vaut mieux gagner
que perdre
alors voilà j'espère que vous avez passé
une appli
champions
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait mais l'enjeu
enrique toutes les ce mec est à
salamé
les gens lui disent albion
toute équipe qui l'a aidé à faire cette
émission et ne venez pas dire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu